When we see artificial intelligence, you know, what what is it
that comes to mind we picture.
A situation where we have these humanoids these Androids
these robots.
who are
If not, as if not Superior to us in
a talents, they are equal to wasn't intelligence. Now. You
see this in many movies, you know these robots.
They have very human-like.
Intellectual capabilities and there are two two.
What do we call it two?
groups of
thinking
And one group we have people say who advocate for developing artificial
intelligence.
Because you know we can train these robots. We
can build these robots who will help us, you know, improve the quality
of our life.
You know to use economic terms increase improve our
utility.
We can do less work.
whether it's the boreas work,
you know working in the mines or
You know anything that is physically demanding
or even you know situations like
this where you have to do very laborious.
technical work
and these robots can come here and do the
work for us or call at least at the various collaborate with us and you
know, make our lives easier.
And the second group of people have this perception, right
if we make them too smart.
Then it will be a matter of time before they come and take, you know,
come knocking on our doors and well
you get you get the picture.
There is a there is a one.
Theoretical explanation why?
We cannot produce computers that can.
extrapolate
learn from extrapolation
and there was also a
practical explanation fire why it's not possible to create such, you
know sentient things.
First let's talk about the three categories
of artificial intelligence.
Okay.
We have the most primitive, which is narrow AI.
And the most Superior which is of course Superior.
Narrow AI is really what we call machine learning.
And another name for machine learning as you may you know is
statistical learning. It's really just statistical techniques.
used
on large volumes of data
Basically, it is a lot of the Redundant tasks that
a statistics would do a lot of the every basic arithmetic.
That is that a decision would do and it is automated with
software. That's what machine learning is machine learning is in
very simple terms statistics.
automated
now
obviously there's more to a status job than
calculating simple things like
dispersion and variation
But a lot of it is automated a lot of the things that
a session would do in order to perform dialysis is
very mundane machine learning automates machine
learning about automating most of that.
Okay.
And it will only a machine learning model will be useful
so long as there is no such as so
long as there's no significant concept shift now.
Now that I've had concept shift. This is in order
to explain what that is. We have to go to different realm. Basically. It is
a significant shift in the distribution of data, and that
isn't the realm of ml Ops machine learning Ops
by the way, if you want to know what Machinery offices I've recorded a
workshop you can watch that and you can you can see what that is.
So it's about machine learning put a production. So and these three next workshops. We're
going to look at machine learning on our computers.
but
we don't want to just be on the computer. We want it to be on the cloud. But then once
it's on the cloud you need to monitor it that's what level Ops is about. Anyway, I just
want to let's stick to here and
I'll tell you what we can learn more about machine learning.
Anyway, so we have three layers.
narrow AI is
using machine learning to do very
well narrow tasks, for example.
Speech to text.
For example, it's like a
narrow.
As a human being you're capable of doing many things,
correct.
You're able to perform any tasks.
Make a sandwich.
Make a telephone call recognize somebody's
face and greet them and so on.
So all of these are narrow tasks that we
are capable of doing and now ai is using machine
learning to machine learning to do to use one of these to perform
one of these now tasks.
Speech text is an example where you listen to audio.
And then you make a transcript of it.
If you go to YouTube and you play a video there is the closed caption
option when you click the Switch.
and
there is the text corresponding to the speaking
person.
It's not accurate all the time. There's a lot of mistakes
in it, but that's an example of narrow AI.
Now the ones image classification what you feed the model of
pictures and the model will say this is a card. This is a truck. This is a cat
Etc.
Now we are currently here.
Generally AI.
Is where we just stage where?
The system we have whether it's using machine learning
or a combination of machine learning and rules-based systems
rules bases you but the the construction program
if and else statements that kind of thing.
So generally is where we have a system.
That can't that is equal to us.
in a
intellectual capacity
so if you have a system that can
learn like you think like you communicate like
you then we have reached General AI.
Now why is it? Why are we quite far
from getting to Super AI?
In order for us to get to Super AI.
That is a stage where?
Machines are superior to us and intelligence.
Who was first be able to replicate our own intelligence?
It makes sense, right? How can we exceed ourselves if
we cannot replicate our metal capabilities?
that is
getting to General AI so and why are we not able to get
the general AI?
because
What is a human being like what what is it?
That makes us intelligent? It's our brain.
Yes.
well, the thing is we don't know much about we don't know as
much about as we don't know much about the brain as much as
we
want to know
And this is not realm of biology and psychology. We
know a great deal about the paint but not enough to replicate
it.
you know, you've heard the story, you know, what what they
examine Einstein's brain just to see what's going on.
We still don't know. What what's we don't we still don't know all the
intricacies of human brain. So, how could we supersede? How
can we ever produce a just a super? Yeah, if we don't
even know how our own brains work.
And we still here.
So this is a practically commission. There's also a theoretical explanation but
That's discussion for a later time.
having said that
of all the machine learning techniques that we have available to us deep
learning is the most sophisticated why because deep
learning is the is our
attempt to replicate the human brain
as close as possible.
so deep learning
Is how we can never get to this point if we can get to
this point?